hour because the men that go to church
have less body count than the women that
go to church yeah I know but no but I
think that's why though because the men
that actually understand female nature
they think this is nonsense it's all the
symptoms
you know what we call these women a new
horse and we don't know what to do so
you know we've got to make some weight
like Mandy really nice they're
Christians that you take them because
nobody at outside church is going to
want them so they might as well take the
ones that everything no I I think they
want to keep the women single in the
church because they have to make money
off of them like each each girl gives
how much a week and like that's that's
the thing it's kind of like it's weird
because they ask for donations but when
there's more single homeless women for
the age of like that's the fastest
growing homeless population single women
and so if they're if they're giving like
a hundred bucks a week let's say that's
400 a month times that by a year that
that's a retirement account